hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 8
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet you may have
recognized a couple things during this
episode at least thematically they were
paying homage to the horror films from
the 1930s to the 1950s from RKO Pictures
like for instance the nth metal
meteorite is kind of an easter egg from
the thing from another world if you
remember the movie the thing most people
just remember john carpenter's version
of that movie that his movie is actually
a remake of a 1951 movie called the
thing from another world so there were a
lot of things like that
in this episode the actual title of the
episode night of the hawk is taken from
an RKO film from 1957 called night of
the demon as you can see these are the
demons but if you watched any of those
classic horror films you'll probably see
some familiar bits but the other really
cool thing about this episode I don't
know if they planned it like this when
they were planning the episode but the
person who directed the episode Joe
Dante also made both gremlins films
Innerspace the burbs what was the
mystery of the burbs this really idyllic
community was something really crazy
going on with one specific family and
something really gruesome happening in
their basement Vandal Savage
keeping the enth metal meteorite in his
man cave down below his house so there
just like a lot of meta things going on
with this episode both behind the scenes
in both in the actual story those are
actually pretty much most of the Easter
eggs there weren't a whole lot of comic
book things going on it mostly just
Easter eggs from those classic movies as
well as the 80s horror so let's do top
five WTF starting with number five the
crew is starting to feel the negative
side effects of time travel I feel like
they're setting something up for a
future episode something really crazy is
gonna happen like they'll have time
traveled for too long and it'll tear
them apart but after this week's episode
they got left in 1959 so I'll explain
what's happening in the next episode
because there will be a two-week break
and I feel like eventually one of the
other crew members will go crazy from
having spent too much time time
traveling if this were Doctor Who they
would actually start to get charged with
the same type of energy that powers the
TARDIS number four WTF they just happen
to run into Vandal Savage walking alone
in the woods looking for a meteorite so
they don't really explain how Vandal
Savage found that meteorite only that it
was calling to him so maybe he was
somewhere in America but I think it's
totally Helene
is that he just out walking in the
Vancouver woods somewhere it's almost
like a classic x-files episode where you
just you happen to be out in the woods
with your friends and you come across a
crazy guy with a meteorite mostly you
are familiar with the cartoon versions
and the comic book versions of Hawkman
and Hawkgirl enth metal is also a metal
that they use to make their armor make
their mace it also gave them their
powers like they explained in the
episode now Vandal Savage also got his
powers from a meteor but it's a
different kind of meteor in the comics
but you get the idea mutagenic
properties just twist people in
different ways that's why it was
literally turning all these people into
Hawks number three WTF infiltrating the
super racist super backwater town so we
have no idea where this is it just meant
to be this Mayberry type town but I do
like the way they put that spin on it
where it's like yeah if you're not a
white male you're not gonna be very
popular here they get a couple digs in a
martin stein oh I loved it when I was
this age I had a bike just like that oh
it was so nice oh yeah you were a
straight white dude so of course
everybody loved you number two WTF
vandal savage's swingers party I love
how crazy things got like he was so nuts
in this episode getting his creep on
John Waters style just all up in
hawkgirl's business I knocked him a
little bit for telegraphing the end
because the minute Hawkgirl was like no
I'm gonna do this alone I'm gonna go try
and stab him alone you knew she was
gonna fail the whole theme is that they
have to come together as a team so
anytime one of them is like no I'm gonna
do this by myself you know it's gonna
fail I say probably the number one WTF
was Vandal Savage
turning Jax into a hawk person part hawk
part firestorm Hawk storm I would be
interested to see what would happen if
Hawkgirl could manifest her powers and
join the firestorm matrix if she would
retain all of her powers if it'd be like
a burning hawk I guess we'd have to call
her fire bird or something like that
that would actually be pretty
spectacular but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from this episode and which classic
horror films did you recognize in this
it was a little bit x-files little bit
Stepford Wives little Pleasantville
little bit classic horror I guess you
could think of all those Hawk people as
gremlins after midnight they all go
crazy didn't see any of them get wet
though but I do really want to watch the
old gremlins movie now so what's gonna
happen is like you saw at the end of the
episode
Cronos boarded their ships so they had
to take off they're gonna come back for
the others later but in the next episode
it will address what they do while the
ship is gone because for them time will
move normally we're gonna see the return
of Racial ghoul the matinee boat Rachele
ghoul from arrow season 3 from before
Oliver killed em but the way they
explained it is is that like ray and
Kendra go off and and start a life
together because it's still 1959 where
they are Sandra decides to go back to
the League of Assassins so that's how we
Siri shall go again but this is 1950s
racial goal so I love the way that he's
gonna look the exact same because of the
Lazarus Pit they kind of explained that
on arrow with a few turns of phrase
about how he just lives an incredibly
long life but get hype and I know
Captain America dropped earlier today
what's happening tomorrow is I have a
new daredevil teaser I'll do a video for
that and then I have a game of Thrones
Q&A that I'm gonna do and he'd announce
the giveaway winner from that and a lot
of you have been asking about my Gotham
video this week but I think you may have
missed that I started posting those on
Facebook I do have a Facebook page I
have Twitter Instagram all the links for
that or at the bottom of the description
so that seems like I've dropped the show
I'm probably just posting the videos on
Facebook so no worries so why you guys
wait for me to post that daredevil video
you can click here to watch the Captain
America trailer 5 billion more times and
you can click here to learn about how
the flash might end the series once it's
done after like season 7 thanks so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight